Salut! Aujourd'hui on est jeudi et le jeudi je fais des choses un petit peu différentes,
je parle de ce que je veux!
Alors on va parler d'argent.
D'argent et d'énigmes.
J'ai une énigme à vous soumettre.
Evidemment il y aura la solution à la fin de la vidéo, n'y allez pas tout de suite !
Cette énigme c'est avant tout une histoire.
C'est l'histoire de trois amis, ils sont autour d'une table et ils dînent.
Chacun mange ce qu'il veut.
Chacun boit ce qu'il veut.
À la fin du repas ils demandent la note, et la note est de 25€.
En clair, ils ont pas déjeuné dans une brasserie à Paris.
À la limite dans un kebab, et encore ils ont pas pris de frites!
Les trois amis mettent chacun 10€ sur la table.
Ils sortent tous les trois un billet de 10.
Et mettent chacun 10€ sur la table.
La serveuse passe.
Elle encaisse les trois billets de 10.
Et elle ramène 5 pièces de 1€.
Parce qu'elle est maligne!
En restauration, il y a une technique pour avoir un pourboire,
c'est de pas ramener un billet,
mais de casser le billet en pièces.
Donc c'est ce qu'elle fait.
Elle est maligne !
Et elle a bien raison la serveuse parce que ça fonctionne.
Chacun des trois amis
récupère une pièce de 1€
donc ils récupèrent 1€ chacun
sur les 5€
Il reste donc 2€ sur la table
et ils décident d'un commun accord :
de les laisser en pourboire
à la serveuse qui, de toute manière, était très sympathique.
Et ça, ça me pose un problème.
Non pas que c'est pas bien de laisser un pourboire,
ça c'est pas le soucis !
Mais si on calcule, ils ont chacun donné un billet de 10€.
Ils ont chacun récupéré 1€.
Donc ça fait 9€ chacun.
Jusque là, ça va !
Ils ont été trois à faire exactement la même chose,
donc 3x9 = 27€.
Plus les 2€ de la serveuse,
ça nous fait 27+2=29 euros
Ils sont passés où les 1 euros manquants?
27+2=29, alors qu'il y a 30 euros au départ
et avec les 3 billets de 10
Où sont passés les 1 euros?
Un billet de 10
avec une pièce de 1 récupérée
ça nous fait 9 euros
fois 3=27
Plus les 2 euros de la serveuse
29, il manque 1 euro
Et à priori ils sont pas sous la table
Je vous laisse chercher, c'est une énigme que je connais depuis longtemps qui m'a toujours amusée
La réponse sera à la toute fin de la vidéo
Comme ça si vous ne voulez pas la regarder tout de suite, ne la regardez pas, vous pouvez chercher à la faire,
vous pouvez aussi poser l'énigme à d'autres personnes
Si ce format un peu différent vous a plu vous pouvez me le faire savoir
Si il manque 1 euro, il faut pas qu'il manque un pouce en l'air par contre
Si vous commentez, je vous lis et je vous répond, vous pouvez aussi vous abonner à la chaîne
Si vous décidez de ne pas regarder la réponse, alors rendez-vous demain à  17h pour le prochain Mental Vlog, chao!
Alors, ils sont passés où ces 1 euros ?
Est-ce-qu'on les a vraiment perdus?
En fait on a pas perdu les 1 euros
Mathématiquement parlant, ce que je vous ai dit n'est pas logique
Ils ont payé 25 euros de repas, ça c'est sûr et certain puisque la note était de 25 euros
Comme ils ont laissé 2 euros de pourboire à la serveuse, ça fait 27
25+2, c'est ce qu'ils ont vraiment dépensé tous les 3
Ils ont récupéré les 3 euros via une pièce chacun
Ça fait bien les 30 euros
C'était une erreur de calcul de faire 27+2 puisque dans les 27, il y avait déjà les 2 euros de pourboire
Peut-être que vous avez déjà trouvé par vous-même , c'est pas évident à trouver donc si c'est le cas bravo, et si c'est pas le cas c'est normal
En attendant, prenez soin de vous et rendez-vous demain à 17h pour le prochain Mental Vlog, chao!